Oh my god, the first challenge.
Oh, sorry, I was late.
The first challenge was getting this game to fucking work on PC!
I was just like... I spent an hour just trying to fucking figure out how to get this game to run!
And then, thank god you guys... I should have asked you guys for help in the beginning because I was just like, how?
How do I make this work?
Oh, so I've never seen this intro, so I guess we watch this intro.
Look, it's a pretty bird!
That's me, I'm that bird.
Oh my god, who are all these characters?
The only guy I know is like, King, because he's like half jaguar or some shit.
Oh my god, this is so hard.
This song is hype.
Is Sound Guy here?
Yeah, I had to do admin mode and then compatibility.
That's how we had to do this.
It was the first challenge.
The first challenge in this game.
Alright, Sound Guy, good, you're here.
I don't know any of these characters.
I'm literally going in blind as a...
I'm going in fucking blind.
I have overall 10 minutes of tech and gameplay over in the series in general.
Fighting game wise, maybe like a couple of hours, but that was because I was like, that was Lil Doki playing the Marvel slash Street Fighter arcade machines.
Whoa, there he is!
There's King!
Where are these other guys?
Oh my god, he has a gun!
Wait, is he OP?
Yes.
That's all I know.
He has a gun.
Can I do anything with that?
Bro, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The lore about Tekken is about a very dysfunctional family and daddy issues.
Gameplay is a panda and a space samurai.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Wait, who's OP?
Oh, I'm not sure.
Who's meta?
Is anybody meta right now?
Tekken 8.
Alright, the issue is that how many times am I going to crash?
Because apparently you can crash a lot in this game.
Or am I just going to be picking Eddy?
Because everyone's like, go pick Eddy!
And then what was it?
Spam something.
Surely the people that might...
You can...
Okay.
Alright.
Wait, I'm using controller though.
Wait, do I use controller?
Uh...
Do I just use controller?
Pick the funny Eddy, my beloved.
What's 3?
You guys just can't say 3!
I don't know what 3 is!
Like, which controller?
I'm using an Xbox controller.
Do I use controller or keyboard?
Tekken is 3.
Okay.
Which...
What's 3?
Okay, I assume that...
What is 3?
There's no 3 here!
It starts at 12!
What do you guys mean 3?
No, it starts at 5!
There's not even a 3 anywhere!
There's not even...
It literally starts at 4!
It starts at 4 and not 3?
Like...
So...
So yes, the reason why...
Mercy, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you, thank you!
Meta is too hard.
Spam A on Eddy or spam Y on Victor.
Oh, A!
Okay, that's great.
I love the A button.
Okay.
So, the reason why I'm playing Tekken at the moment is because I got invited to the...
Was it the Seijam...
Seijam Slam tournament?
Seijam?
Se...
I'm sorry!
Because that's the word I should say!
Seijam?
Is it Seijam or Seijam?
Seijam.
Okay, Seijam Slam 2 tournament.
And I have 0 experience.
I was like, but I have 0 experience.
And they're like, perfect.
I'm just as surprised as you guys that I'm in the tournament as well.
I literally told him.
He's like, oh my gosh, you invited me.
I was like, but I have 0 experience.
And he's like, perfect.
That's what we need.
I was like, okay.
Little does he know, I also have 0 experience overall.
The perfect target.
DDragon, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Correct me if I'm wrong.
But 1 equals X, 2 equals Y, A equals 3, and 4 equals B.
Also, King has a couple of grabs that do a ton of damage.
And newbies cannot break.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
So, yes, I'm very thankful to get invited as well.
For those who also don't know, I also got invited to the Nokia Apex tournament.
I knew about this for a while.
And I was just waiting for it to be announced.
They even sent me like a welcome pack.
Like they sent everybody who's participating a welcome package.
I haven't received it yet.
But I won't spoil it.
I'll tell you who's in my team.
We have a team going in already.
It's a hide and seek tournament too, by the way.
Yeah, I just retweeted it.
I just quote retweeted it.
But we got invited to a Nokia hide and seek Apex tournament.
That's happening at the end of the month.
You guys are going to find out who's on my team later on.
Whenever it's revealed, I have no idea when it's going to be revealed.
I didn't.
I just found out they tweeted it out today.
And then they were like, oh, quote retweet it when you can.
So I was like, okay, I'll do my part.
I'm going to do my part.
But it's okay.
There's a lot of pro players in here.
But like it's hide and seek.
So it's like, what are you going to do?
Hide better?
Like if anything, I'll just follow where the pros are hiding and then grief them if I have to.
Yeah, this is the one that this guy's toasting.
Wig is hosting.
Yeah.
No, but thank you.
Thank you.
French Gil, Victor, go Pew Pew teleport Pew Pew.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And as they give a super chat, thank you.
The fighting game bell curve means by having zero experience, you might be many with limited experience.
Think of the super chat.
Thank you.
So, yeah, I have no idea what to expect in this Tekken 8 tournament because I have no experience at all other than button mashing.
So.
I can button mash better than all those other newbies out there.
If they don't know what I'm going to do, how do they counter?
Exactly.
If I have zero patterns, how do they counter me?
I'm that unpredictable.
Exactly.
I don't know what they're going to be doing, but I know my strat.
Is that it?
Next?
Okay, there you go.
Cross platform.
Do I have one cross platform or should I just play with all the PC people?
Okay, if all else fails and I actually can't...
If all else fails and like I'm actually that too stupid to recognize patterns, I have button mashing my beloved will be here for me.
Barely.
Can you barely see the image?
I don't even see it at all.
We'll just go with equal.
Alright.
Is that...
There we go.
Benchmark score 1028.
Is that good?
I can't tell.
In order to optimize performance.
Alright.
This game has an auto save.
Okay, cool.
Alright, here we go.
They have coaches?
That's true.
But am I coachable?
Please enter your player's name.
Alright, sure.
Real...
Oh, wait.
Everybody's gonna see this name.
So I should...
Actually...
Everybody's gonna see this name.
Wait, I can't type.
How the fuck?
Please use your keyboard.
I'm literally trying to type my name.
Wait, what?
It's not even...
It's not...
My keyboard's actually not registering.
Oh my god.
I have no name.
I can't...
I can't!
I want to!
I actually can!
Oh my god!
Oh wait.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, there we go.
I figured out real.
Okay.
There we go.
What's my name?
Here we go.
Registration complete.
There we go.
We did it.
So real.
Yeah.
Look, Eddy!
Should I buy Eddy right now?
Wait.
We'll be releasing an additional player.
Do I have Eddy unlocked?
Wait, guys.
Give me a sec.
I need to know.
Do I have to buy Eddy?
He's my...
He's my trump card.
It's time to buy Eddy.
Do I have him?
Eddy...
How do I buy Eddy?
How do I buy him?
Not buy him?
Wait.
Do I have him?
I can't tell.
Because I got Tekken 8 for free.
Guys, this is why I got him.
This is a...
This is a joke?
Okay.
I need to preface that this is a joke.
But...
This is why I joined.
I got Tekken 8 for free.
Huge shout out.
They actually...
They gave me a free copy of Tekken 8.
So I didn't have to buy it.
A huge, huge shout out to them for actually...
This is a joke, by the way.
Because I was gonna buy Tekken 8 regardless.
But free is free, you know?
Free...
Free is free.
Nice.
Alright.
Okay.
Introduced.
How do I...
Okay.
Customization.
Where's like options?
Okay.
Options.
Alright.
Sound settings.
How's the sound, by the way?
I mean, I feel like voice has to be always up.
Yay!
Free game!
Woo!
I love it!
Okay.
Button map.
We don't need to know any of that.
Alright.
Let's see.
Offline mode.
Quick match.
Maybe I'll do one quick match and just see how...
How fucked I get.
No, let's just go straight in.
Okay.
So, I'm gonna go straight in.
Bring music.
Okay.
Enjoy battling with new style.
Use techin' aids to easily master your favorite characters' unique moves and combos.
Even if you're new to using...
Enjoy fighting without to memorize.
Oh, cool!
Press X to unleash a heat engager, ideal for offensive play.
If heat is already activated, your heat here...
Quick match is...
Quick match is what?
Oh my god.
Press Y for a combo starter.
Press Y to repeatedly...
How many instructions are there?
Press A, you can activate power crush, a counter attack used when getting attacked.
Press A when you think an opponent is...
Oh, this is a counter!
Okay.
Draws can be performed with B, B, B.
RB is a button that unleashes the heat system's special moves.
Perform a heat smash by pressing RB.
During heat, you'll go into a rage mode when your health is low.
This boosts your attack power and you'll be able to use your rage art with RT.
Rage...
What the fuck am I?
Turn on special style?
Should I turn it on?
Do I...
Do I turn on special?
No?
Okay.
Maybe I shouldn't be in quick match.
Fight against a CPU opponent to calculate your starting rank.
They will still be dedicated based on your performance in battle.
In all live matches, you will be matched against...
Okay.
Alright.
Can I pause CPU battles?
Choose...
I won't be on the left side.
Okay.
Where's Eddy?
No!
I don't have Eddy!
Did my game crash?
How do I select?
I don't have Eddy.
All right.
Sweet!
Oh.
I'm loading.
Okay.
It crashed?
I can't tell!
This game has baited me for so long!
It crashed!
It actually- I can't tell if I've crashed or not!
Oh!
Special style equals aim assistance?
That should not have happened!
Can I turn on special style?
Zeno, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I can't tell!
Is it crushed?
That's not it this week.
Am I...
Am I still in?
No, actually a deep...
No!
I can't tell!
This game has baited me for so long!
I can't tell if it's crushed or not!
Guys, I actually can't tell I crashed.
Never mind, I can tell.
Never mind.
This music is here forever.
Oh, oh.
We're just going to listen to that forever, I guess.
Okay.
Alright.
Well, we got to watch it a little bit.
That was fun.
Guys, we got into the menu.
That was pretty fun, guys!
The game stopped me from going into Quick Match.
Even the game knew it was a bad idea.
The game was like, Doki, please.
Play the tutorial.
I was like, but what if so?
But what if I go straight in?
You learn the hard way, you know?
It's like when those mama birds push their babies off a cliff.
To be like, if you don't fly, you die.
That type of deal, that's me.
If I don't fly, I die.
Look, the best thing about having overall 10 minutes of Tekken knowledge...
is that there's zero expectations of me.
So that's...
And I'm okay with that.
I'm okay with zero expectations.
Unlucky, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Who would have thought Doki's first actual battle in Tekken is with Tekken itself.
Okay, we just need to get past like the...
We just need to get past the fucking main menu.
Alright, here we go.
You turned on the graphics?
I feel like I should.
That sounds very important actually.
Maybe that's why I crashed.
I didn't turn down anything, I just went straight in.
Alright, we gotta turn down the music and then also...
I already brought it up overall.
Guys, I didn't have time to set up my new PC.
I've been so busy.
This is a great start.
What do you think of the game so far?
I mean, with my limited experience...
With my only experience being the main menu...
It seems pretty cool.
You know?
Only been in the game menu.
But like, other than that...
Seems pretty fine.
Alright...
BGM...
Okay...
There you go.
That should be good, right?
Am I in ultra mode?
Oh!
Okay.
That makes a little more sense.
Alright, here we go.
Yes.
That's a yes I am.
Alright, what else do I need?
Do I put on medium?
I think medium sounds like the best area to be in.
So I can...
That seems right.
That seems a lot better.
Alright.
I'll bring it up a little bit more.
Okay, I'll bring up the sound volume a little more.
Let me know if it's better sound guy.
I brought up the sound a little bit more.
Running a skill...
Vsync off?
Okay, Vsync off.
Where's Vsync?
Okay, there we go.
Anything else that I should do?
Medium is premium.
Alright, bring it up.
Remove shadows?
Do I not need shadows?
Okay.
Shadow.
Alright.
There we go.
That should be fine now, right?
We should be good.
Now we don't have to see the pure sweat from this guy.
I'm dripping out.
Oh, I need a bite.
Guys, give me a sec.
I need to buy Eddy.
If all else fails, I have Eddy.
Alright, Tekken shop.
How do I buy Eddy?
I'm going to the shop now.
Guys, this is important.
Eddy!
Okay, I just need to buy the DLC, right?
I already have Tekken 8.
I'm going to buy the DLC.
Wait, how do I...
Eddy, there he is.
How much is he?
Is it $10?
I mean, that's fine.
If all else fails, I have Eddy.
I'll pull out the Eddy if I start losing.
Pay to win.
Let's fucking go.
I got Eddy, guys.
Guys, I did it.
I bought Eddy.
Alright.
That's all I need.
Alright, let's see.
Yay!
Eddy, you know what?
I'm going to buy Eddy.
I'll go with Eddy.
I think I can do a quick match now.
Wait!
Alright, fight me good!
One, two, one!
It's Eddy time!
Alright, it can't be that bad, right?
There's no way.
There's no way it's going to be that bad, right?
Let's go.
It can't be that bad.
If I play Eddy, it should be fine, right?
All I do is just play Eddy.
What it's like to be...
But guys, I need you guys to not play Eddy though.
Only I play Eddy.
Chat, only I.
She's so sad.
What do you mean?
I'll just play Eddy.
It can't be that bad.
Press... what's 3 again?
A, right?
That's... is that right?
A?
How do I... How do people join my lobby?
I'm a real female.
Change your character?
Wait, how do I change my character?
So many things I need to know how to do.
Dragoons this time, show no mercy to our Oshii.
Unlucky, thank you for the super chat.
There's a password?
Oh, there he is!
Mighty.
Mighty ruler?
Wait, is that... is that scary?
Is that...
Trick dookies, beautiful.
Wait, don't pick Eddy though.
Don't pick Eddy.
Only I pick Eddy.
You're playing wrong without any story?
I don't need no story.
How do I change characters?
Guys, guys, I'm not ready.
How do I...
Change characters!
I'll be on the left.
Oh, there you go.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, this took forever.
Eddy!
I brought up the volume, is it better?
Sound guy?
Guys, I'm Eddy.
He might have played before.
How would you know?
Purple Rake might not be that bad.
Guys?
Look, see?
He has... His stats are at D.
Guys?
Look, see?
He has...
His stats are at D.
Guys?
Look, see?
He has...
His stats are at D.
It can't be that bad.
Okay, don't do anything first.
Let me at least have one hit, Kaiser.
Let me at least...
Bring it up more after you get destroyed.
Because all I'm saying is if you're a real Dragoon, you would let me Eddy spam you.
Is that the Street Fighter?
Is that Street Fighter?
Please, give me his... Don't, don't, don't come over yet.
Oh my god.
Don't come over yet, please.
Don't, wait, give me a sec.
Give me a sec.
Don't, don't come over.
What?
What the fuck?
Bro, calm down.
There's no friend.
I got a hit.
It's not a
hit.
I got a
It's not a hit.
Oh yeah.
Oh my god.
Guys, what the fuck?
I thought you were purple.
That's why you can't predict this, right?
That's fucking right.
You can't predict this.
Yes, I got a round.
That's fucking right.
Can't predict this.
You're not perfect anymore.
Not perfect.
That's fucking right.
I got a round.
You can't perfect this.
That's fucking right.
Oh, I don't know what I'm doing.
Because you can't predict this shit.
No way.
How do I spam three?
What is three?
I don't know what is three.
What am I doing?
Is this ping?
I don't know.
I don't know how am I spamming three.
Okay.
How do I block?
What did I do?
Okay.
I did that.
That's right.
No predictions.
Literally only A.
Wait.
What did I do?
How did I do that?
How the fuck did I do that?
It's okay.
He didn't perfect me.
That's okay.
I won.
What the fuck is going on?
Good question.
Wait.
I tried to A.
No perfect.
Shit.
He fucking backed me down.
It's okay.
I won the spirit because I took two rounds off of him.
And now he's...
Oh, that's fucking right.
That's fucking right.
Oh, shit.
I'm trying to spam A.
It's okay.
It's alright.
Did I really lose when I got two rounds off of him?
Did I really lose?
Is it truly a loss where I got two rounds off of this guy?
That's a king right...
I don't know, guys.
I think I...
I think I won here spiritually.
I think...
Fade actor.
Shake my head.
I'm thinking of the super chat.
Thank you.
Did you know what you're doing?
Absolutely not.
I told you.
If...
If it all fails...
Bring out the Eddie.
Let's watch these guys play and then we'll do the tutorial.
I'm willing to watch this.
How do I watch this?
Am I watching?
There are no winners.
All I'm saying...
All I'm saying is that I've managed...
Oh my god.
This guy is S+.
Wait, he wasn't even playing his hero?
Oh my god, this Hitman.
Wait, that's so cool!
The customization is crazy.
Alright I brought up the volume more now...
Sound guy.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, shit.
How do I get rid of the chat?
Chat display.
Alright, there you go.
All right.
If you lose this victory...
You're bad.
I'm...
Oh my god, look!
Oh my god!
Bro!
Look at him!
Okay!
Look at that!
Look at Kaiser!
Fucking...
Look at that!
This guy actually plays the game and look at how much he's losing!
Too cosplay.
I took a round off these two.
Oh my god, never mind.
Wait, these guys are equal.
These guys are like equal.
Man, you're... I feel like maybe I should go low.
The frames are pretty bad.
Holy shit.
I feel like they know what they're doing.
Cause they're actually blocking.
I feel like...
Oh my god!
They actually know what they're doing.
They're like figuring out each other.
Look how there's combos.
How do they do that?
Set up the PC.
But it's so much work.
And I have so much other work to do.
No keep button.
I was very clear on what I was doing.
Oh my god!
I told you guys!
If I button mash, nobody will know what I'm doing.
They can't like counter... They can't counter me if they don't know my patterns.
So he said it.
All I need to know is how to block.
I feel like if I realize...
I feel like if I realize how to block and then I button mash, things will be okay.
The more you play, the less frame drops you will get.
Oh, okay.
It's still compiling.
Okay.
But did you win the set?
I got two rounds off of him.
That's all I'm saying.
Hold back to block?
Oh, okay.
Hold back to block.
Oh shit!
He's getting absolutely destroyed!
Oh my god!
Guys, maybe I'm meant to be PurpleRank.
Maybe I'm meant to be Flame slash MightyRuler.
Hahaha!
Hold down back to block?
Alright.
Alright guys.
Guys, have fun in this custom lobby.
I'm going to do the tutorial for real now.
Guys, leave session.
Sorry guys, I'll see you later.
Apparently I have to actually...
Wow!
I got money!
I got million G's!
Wow!
Apparently I should actually know how to play this game.
Alright, what is the tutorial?
Is it the story?
Or is it offline?
Is it arcade quest?
Practice through an exciting...
Apparently I actually have to learn.
This mode...
Training...
Begins...
Is it arcade quest?
Arcade quest?
Okay.
Arcade quest.
Okay, I got this.
Okay, but for real.
Like, what do I actually play?
Hahaha!
Do I actually go full... Do I commit to the eddy?
Or do I... Do I play King?
Because apparently King is also like...
Good to... Good at destroying noobs too.
And I'm a noob as well.
So if... If I destroy the other noob first...
Then I win.
Play whoever looks cool.
But I want to play whoever is meta.
I want to play whoever... I can use as a crutch.
Whichever character I can use as a fucking crutch.
That's all I want.
There's always plenty of smiles and sounds of button clacking.
King... eddy... Okay.
Uh...
Alright!
Thank you for the gift and shit!
Thank you!
Let's see.
There is no meta... The meta will change on May 9th.
Well, thank god the tournament... Wait.
Isn't it May 9th?
Oh wait!
It's already... It's not May 9th.
Uh...
Do not play King.
As long as I can grab.
Is that all that matters?
As long as I can grab somebody?
I might not know what I'm doing, but I can grab someone?
King is hard.
Darkblade.
Meta this, Meta that.
But have you ever met a girl before?
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Where's your pal at?
They're supposed to be... Oh my gosh!
I'll go look for them.
You guys head out without me.
Which one's me?
Okay, see you then there.
Oh cool, I'll be there when the tourney starts.
Oh that's so cool!
Is this a lobby?
Cool, I'll be thinking of superchat thinking of the Yankee.
Yo, where you at?
This place is packed.
Where the fuck is Max?
Is that you, Dragoons?
Let me know what you're wearing today and I'll come back for you.
Whoa!
He wants to know what we're wearing.
Wait, is this default?
I think I love default face already.
Okay, okay, I like the face already.
Is that face like... whatever you wear.
Bro, I want to keep this face.
I actually like...
Wait, wait, but I could be an absolute chat... oh wait, no.
Does the chat face work?
No.
Okay.
He doesn't say this looks like a chat's face.
Okay, I'm going to keep this.
I actually really like this way.
I can be purple or yellow.
Wait, I can make a Dragoon.
I want to make a Dragoon.
Okay, a Dragoon.
All right, here you go.
And then...
Let's see.
Uh, what kind of hairstyle would work?
I guess this.
And then... oh yeah, this works!
Yeah!
Okay, how do I change the color?
Wait, how do I change the color?
Oh, there you go.
Why?
I read.
There we go.
Okay.
This is a Dragoon!
That's a Dragoon!
What are you saying?
Now you guys have to like, root for me because if I lose, you lose.
All I'm saying, if I lose, you lose.
Because I'm playing as you.
Okay.
All right, let's see.
I want a beard.
What is that?
What's the.
Oh, there's a beard...
It's a beauty mark.
Okay, wait, wait.
Do I want...
Let's see.
Actually, we'll do this one.
Yeah.
And then...
Perfect.
What is that?
That's you!
It's you!
It's the dragons!
Dragons!
Alright, what do we want you to wear?
Cover everything up.
No, I worked so hard for this.
Oh, I can have hats too!
No, we can't cover this.
We can't cover this.
Okay, let's see.
Is there anything else?
Oh, wait, we should have a different...
We should wear something different though.
Let's see.
Oh my God, you guys can be edgy.
Do I have money?
I do!
I have money!
Alright, I want you guys to wear something edgy.
Oh my God, yes!
Yes!
For our king cosplay!
Alright, and then... What do you want for your pants?
I mean, I have a million dollars.
It should be fine.
I feel ins... Why are you insulted?
You look beautiful!
Okay.
What do you think about what pants to wear?
Oh, short shorts.
Short shorts!
Oh, wait, there's more.
Okay, wait.
Short shorts!
Alright, here you go.
This is our king cosplay.
And then shoes.
I actually like...
Yes!
Oh my God, you guys look fabulous!
Uh...
And then we have a friendship bracelet.
But you guys don't see it.
You guys don't see the friendship bracelet.
It's here in spirit!
It's here in spirit.
Alright.
Nice!
I finished.
This is you guys.
Looks like someone court ordered to...
...been enjoying some month.
Ginger, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, finish editing.
Save and exit.
I'm the dragon.
I'm... Dragon!
Dragon!
You're looking at yourself!
You're beautiful!
Are you trying to say you're not beautiful?
Because I think you're beautiful!
Look at you guys!
I hope I didn't crash because I tabbed out.
I'm good.
There you go.
I didn't think it was super...
There you are!
I was trying to think you weren't gonna show.
Man, my heart's beating like crazy.
I feel like...
I feel electricity in the air.
We've all been waiting for this game to drop for what feels like forever and a day!
You see any free machines?
Yo, this one!
This is Tekken 8 at last!
Oh, hold on.
Did you play any of the previous games?
Absolutely not.
Play all the tutorials.
Yeah.
Don't sweat it.
Don't call me the Tekken prop and my local arcade for nothing.
I can show you the ropes.
No problem.
Okay.
Are we learning...
Did I... did I crash?
Guys, I got ready for the next battle and then I crashed.
You fucking...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Wow, Doki, you're homeless, bread, sims, and cosplay looks off.
Guys, I got ready for the next battle and then it was over.
Please, let me at least do the tutorial.
Please.
Oh my god.
That's all I want.
I couldn't even get ready for the next battle, everybody.
No!
I got baited.
I got... I got baited.
I can only enjoy...
the sound of the battle.
Zachary, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You made a character worthy of Dr. Krusty.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Did I save?
Did I save my dragoon?
I was not ready.
Yeah, I was absolutely not ready.
Guys, did it save?
Did it save, guys?
No!
You just lost.
Okay.
Guys, no!
No!
I just want to get ready for the next...
Don't you have a monster PC?
Yeah, it's sitting outside my room.
I haven't even unboxed it yet.
I just didn't have the time to set up.
I was so busy.
Antonio, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Your very first super chat.
I really appreciate it.
Antonio.
Hey, thanks for accurately depicting my severe...
feeling the love.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, we're going to lower the quality a little bit.
Maybe it's the graphics.
Maybe.
Okay, medium.
What else do we lower?
What else can we lower though?
Guys.
But you need the PC.
Maybe it'll get better.
You don't know that.
Go window mode.
Would window mode actually help?
At this point, go to 480.
Anti-aliased?
Okay, we're going to do it with...
Maybe the anti-aliased will help.
Alright, here we go.
This is it.
This time.
I'm ready for the battle.
Alright, this is it.
This is going to turn this into a Dokian chat...
while she finally sets up her new PC stream.
Dazzy, Dazzy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is it.
Please don't make me remake the dragons.
Oh, yes.
No!
That's not me!
Wait.
Yes?
No, that's not me.
No!
Please save my dragons!
It didn't save!
Oh, it did!
Oh my god!
I knew it.
You're here forever.
Airboy Ninja, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
PC's haunted.
I knew it.
You're here forever.
Now you got it.
Yes!
Tekken remembers.
This is your...
This is like...
You know, what was it called?
You know, like when they turn like Pokemon into human design?
What's the word for it?
That's your real design when you're a person.
You know like artists who used to like...
make like...
Yeah.
G-Jinkas?
That's...
That's you guys.
That's your G-Jinka form.
G-Jinkas!
No!
It's still okay.
It's just loading.
It's just...
Your PC is actually dying.
We're so...
You're not ugly!
It's like the most accurate representation.
Trust the...
It's okay!
Just trust!
We didn't crash!
It's just loading!
Guys... No it's not!
It's not crashed!
Guys Tekken 8 has baited me so much!
It's just bait!
If all else fails, I'll just use the Playstation version of Tekken.
Just ask me...
No!
It can't have crashed!
There's no way!
Please!
At least let me...
Alright, we're gonna do window mode.
Why does it take forever to load?
I don't understand!
Alright guys...
Alright guys, we're gonna...
Guys, we might have crashed.
Or it might have been...
I think you guys were right.
We should have done windowed mode.
You know, it's fine.
It's funny that... You know what's great guys?
We gotta play...
We gotta play like one match.
No it's not dead!
Don't say that!
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
It shouldn't change this to a PC set up stream.
Look, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Look!
I'll... I'll make sure I'll have the new PC ready before the tournament!
I swear!
I'll have the new PC ready for the tournament!
Just not right now!
I just didn't have time!
50 FPS, that's almost playable.
Thank you for the Akka super.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you for the...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I get to play one match though.
I got that one match in me.
Alright, okay guys.
Let me play window mode.
Maybe that's it.
That's it!
This is what we needed!
Guys...
This is what we needed guys.
We'll play...
All we need is to...
Is to play window mode.
That's all we need!
Razzy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, graphics settings.
Alright, window... borderless.
Borderless?
Borderless should be fine, right?
Okay.
It's because I was playing on...
It's because I was playing on full screen.
Now I'm on borderless.
Now we're okay.
This is it.
I swear, we're not doing...
If I can't even fucking play the tutorial...
I'm just gonna go into a quick match.
I'll learn live.
I'll just...
I'll learn the game live.
With actual people.
There we go.
Skip movie.
Yeah!
You guys are finished editing!
Guys...
It's moving!
The 8 is moving!
Oh my god, there I am!
I showed up!
We showed up!
I knew it!
It's all because of the borderless!
Oh nice, it saved again.
Alright, this is it.
Get ready for the next battle!
I'm ready!
Guys, it might be stuttering.
But the 8 is moving.
The 8 will move.
It's moving.
The particles are moving a little bit.
It moved.
It's okay.
Alright.
X is left.
Y...
Right punch.
B...
Right click... kick.
A... left kick.
Okay, I got this.
Okay.
Arm...
Right...
And then kick.
Okay.
We got it.
Oh!
And then this is how I do the Eddy spam, right?
But I'm not Eddy though.
Just practicing my Eddy right now.
On the wrong character.
Okay.
We're fine.
Alright, nice.
Let's try some important man inputs.
What the fuck?
Oh shit, is that a combo?
I can do that.
Oh, look at me go!
Uh...
Directional input.
Okay.
There.
I did it.
Wait how did I do that?
How do I do that?
Did I do it?
You see how I pressed the button early?
How do I?
That's it.
Okay.
Did I not do it?
I didn't!
See, it said great!
There you go.
I did it!
Wait, directional input?
Oh my god.
Did I do it?
Yeah!
Robin, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I'm good to go now.
You heard that?
They said I'm good to go.
Should I be using D-pad or...
Guys, am I supposed to use the D-pad or the directional or the analog stick?
That PC is heading to the...
D-pad?
Oh, okay, because I was using the analog stick.
Okay, now I know.
Actually, that means losing your own health is bad.
Yeah, of course.
Yeah, why are you beating me up?
Hey, hold you can... Oh!
That's how you block!
I figured it out.
Try to block and hack.
Boom!
Oh, wait.
There we go.
I figured out how to block.
Look at me go.
All right, now I know what you're thinking.
You stand there and block everything.
You never lose.
Yeah!
But there's this issue of low attacks and throws that can't be blocked using... Oh, so I have to block by...
I have to like... go to the...
Go down.
Okay.
You can use a crouching.
Okay, to do a crouching block.
Okay, I got it.
Try to block a low attack.
Boom!
Just block everything.
If I block everything, they can never do damage.
Yeah!
That's right.
Woo!
Perfect!
I lay out the basics!
I did it!
All right, tech unit heat system.
What's this?
Now I'm gonna teach you about the heat.
It's a super important battle system.
If you notice that you have another gauge besides the health gauge, that's the heat timer.
When you have a heat timer, it means you're able to activate heat.
You start every round in this state.
How to do that?
Uh...
RB.
Okay.
Ooh!
Heat activated.
You can see the timer looks different now.
Your character is stronger if you activate.
However, there is a time limit so you don't stay strong forever.
So you can only use it once per round.
So timing is key.
Oh, that's easy.
I'll just use it in the beginning.
Hahaha!
Also, moves are only available when heat...
Try busting out a heat smash now.
That it?
Nice!
All right.
He smashes it and it's the only good thing about heat state.
You can only add...
You can also get the added bonus of chip damage with all your moves.
Your opponent...
Oh!
So they're both...
They can't block my moves!
Technically.
I see.
Recommended air combo when heat activation activated.
What?
The fuck?
Tekken is all about the air combo.
And then...
What?
Is that it?
No.
Wait.
Did I do it?
Heat activation during...
What?
Okay, wait.
And then I do it...
Do it again?
Oh!
Okay.
I forgot to press it the second time.
Hahaha!
All right.
I'm learning.
I didn't read the last half.
They got me in the first half.
Not gonna lie.
Master the ballast is next.
You have to pick a character and get fighting.
Okay.
They got me in the first half.
All right.
My game crashed.
But I was so ready!
I was so ready though!
I was so ready!
I was about to pick everything!
I don't understand!
Hahaha!
Okay.
I'll try DLSS.
I got the shader error!
I got the shader one.
Hahaha!
I don't understand!
I did everything for Tekken!
Please.
The game got Doki in the first half.
Not gonna lie!
Hahaha!
I still have my PC set up before the tournament!
I promise!
Anton, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Broku, thank you for the super chat!
You're actually learning!
I think you actually have a game sense and gaming skills become good at the game!
Okay.
I don't know how much copium you're on right now.
Thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
Okay.
All right.
It's time to go even lower than before.
It's time to go as low as we can.
We don't need to see the graphics, guys!
We don't need to see the man's pores!
So much hope you are doing well!
Thank you for the super chat, Brian!
Thank you!
All right.
Let's hope we can...
We'll put everything...
It's time to put everything on low.
It's time.
Okay.
All right.
We don't need to look at the man's pores, guys.
Like, we don't need to know what's going on.
We don't need to know what's going on with his skin.
All right.
Let's see.
What is this?
Is there DLS here?
AMD.
AMD performance balance quality.
NIS.
DLS ultra performance balance quality.
There we go!
That sounds about right!
There we go.
We're on the quality sector.
Okay.
Here we go.
Not quality.
Oh, wait.
We won performance.
Okay.
Wait.
Where is it?
Where's performance?
Okay.
There we go.
Performance.
Not quality.
Here we go.
There it is!
We'll be fine now, guys.
Surely!
All right, guys.
We don't need arcade anymore.
It's time.
Let's do the Eddie episodes!
Where's Eddie?
Select story mode difficulty.
You know what?
Medium.
Let's go.
Eddie.
I learned how to block.
Where's Eddie?
Where's E for Eddie?
Wait.
There's no Eddie episodes?
Is he not important?
I find Eddie important.
Is there King at least?
There's no King?
How is he not important enough to have his own story?
Oh, spicy.
I guess we'll do the Dark Awakens.
Up until...
Would you like to go before starting the story mode?
For first time players.
Okay.
Sure.
What's the story anyway?
How long are these?
Tekken 4 summary?
Okay.
Let's just read what's going on in 7.
King is right.
Right there.
Who is that guy?
Maybe I should not have started with Tekken 7.
Is this a spoiler?
I mean, it's Tekken 7.
Seven?
We've taken your gamer rig for granted.
Gary, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, this guy is dead.
Whoever this guy is.
Only we can stop... Kazuya?
I'm Kazuya!
I can stop Kazuya!
The devil's blood.
Oh my god!
He grew tattoos!
We figured it out, guys.
We figured out the story.
Alright, I guess that was the story.
So can we play now?
Fight money.
Why do I need to purchase... Oh, it says the gallery.
Oh!
Wait, someone said King is actually in there.
Where's King?
A, B, C, D, E, F... Oh, King!
Alright, let's try it!
Okay, apparently King grabs are good.
King, that's me!
Wait, so why does he have a jaguar head?
Because of the Because it's cool.
He's so cool.
Okay, it can't be a mask.
He's literally talking in growls.
Like, unless he's super immersive.
I'm getting old.
Why not?
That's me!
He does it for the children.
I'll be fighting against the law?
How do I grab?
I realized I've learned everything but grabbing.
And that's this whole thing.
Witness the might of the undisputed champion.
Guys, I realized there was one thing I didn't learn.
Oh, but did you see the block though?
Oh shit!
Oh fuck, okay.
Alright.
It's fine.
We gotta use this heat moment before the round ends.
Oh shit.
It's fine.
Oh fuck, I still don't know how to grab.
That grab!
A or X?
Okay, A, X.
Or A, B.
Alright, I blocked that.
Two.
Okay.
There you go.
I'm grabbing.
Let me grab!
They don't know how to counter grab!
Grab!
I did it!
Oh my god, this is it!
I'll just keep grabbing!
I figured it out!
It's over.
It's over for all the other noobs.
I don't even know how to break a grab.
It's over.
Oh shit, wait a minute.
Oh shit.
No, no, no, no, no!
Let me grab you!
Okay.
I got the strat!
Okay, maybe not.
Guys, maybe I should stop that.
Okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Yes!
No King's Lair knows how to break the grab.
It sounds accurate.
If I keep grabbing!
This is it!
I just gotta keep grabbing!
Let me grab you!
Okay.
Yes!
We figured it out!
Oh shit.
I quit.
That's right.
Can't counter the grab.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
This is coming, King.
Alright.
Winner's playoff.
Here we go.
Alright.
We figured it out.
Go King.
Go.
How is she doing that?
Okay.
No one.
No, none of the noobs know how to counter grabs.
Because I don't know how to counter it.
Oh shit.
That's fucking right.
No, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no.
Wait, how you countered me?
You're an NPC!
That's fucking right.
That's fucking right!
How do you counter this?
No!
Oh shit.
Don't worry.
I still can grab you.
That's fucking right.
Oh god.
No!
He countered the grab!
No way.
Nice.
There we go.
It's okay.
I just keep grabbing.
There's no way.
There we go.
That's fucking right!
Check the PC.
The NPC is learning about my grabs!
How?
How is he learning?
Oh shit.
Oh fuck.
Okay.
He's countering my grabs!
How?
I don't know how to counter.
Oh god.
Oh no.
He's juggling me.
Oh god.
Oh no.
He's juggling me.
Guys.
This might be it.
The NPC is learning.
He cancelled it.
How did he cancel?
Oh god.
No.
Nice.
This is a strat!
I just know xA and what was the other grab?
Try up xA.
Oh xY.
Okay.
The AI is self-aware.
Guys.
Oh!
Why did I try xY?
No.
Oh no.
He's learning!
He knows my magic!
He knows!
Oh my god.
How does he know?
Okay.
Nice.
There we go.
Okay.
Nice.
There we go.
Grab!
Boom!
That's fucking right!
I'll just keep grabbing!
Oh shit.
Okay.
Never mind.
I'm so sorry.
Nice.
I'm doing it.
There we go.
Grab tab.
Okay.
Oh my god.
It would be crazy if he knew.
If actually people...
It would be crazy if the newbies actually learned how to counter the grab.
I would be so sad.
That would be so sad.
Because this is actually my whole strat.
Oh god.
Please!
No, no, no, no, no!
Yes!
The grab!
Alright.
Here we go.
He has multiple grab.
Hahaha.
Help!
There's coaching?
It's okay!
They're not gonna register!
They're not gonna register.
There's no way.
Try running and then grab?
Oh my god.
I should try that.
Okay.
Never mind.
Oh!
No!
I tried!
I fucking... Okay.
Okay, nice.
I got the grab here.
Nice.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Block!
There you go.
No, come on!
Yes!
No!
Holy shit!
He's insane!
They have Steve Learn!
I can't believe it!
Steve Learn!
Did I grab him?
Nice.
Okay.
Oh my god.
I grabbed him again.
That's fucking right.
Get grabbed.
Come on.
I'll just keep grabbing.
Come on!
Come on, King!
Just keep grabbing!
Yes!
Keep grabbing!
Oh shit!
No!
Just grab him back!
Oh god!
Oh no!
Steve, no!
Oh god!
Just...
No!
I got...
I got out-grabbed!
Oh!
Oh god.
Okay.
That's fine.
It's my turn.
That's fucking right.
Oh shit!
No!
Steve, have mercy!
Let me grab you!
Come on.
Let me grab you.
Come on!
I just need one grab!
I literally just...
Oh my god!
He's so good!
Steve is so good!
Holy shit!
I'm getting out-catted!
Oh my god!
He perfectly...
Oh Steve!
My skill wall!
There's no way there's gonna be a newbie!
There's no way there's gonna be a newbie that's just as good as Steve!
I refuse!
I really...
There's no way!
I refuse to believe that!
Okay.
It's okay.
We might not be able to grab him as well as...
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Okay.
No.
Please stop doing that.
Please.
Don't make me use it.
This...
Okay.
I blocked.
My turn.
That's right.
That's fucking right!
Yes!
Oh god.
Okay.
Grabbing the- No!
No, it's over for you.
That's fucking right.
Oh god.
He blocked it.
Yeah!
You did block shit!
That's fucking right!
I figured it out.
I'm learning.
I blocked and then grabbed.
Here we go.
Just you wait and see.
Wait.
I think I do it!
There's no way!
There's no way the other noobs can learn how to counter a block- a grab.
How would they learn?
They will.
There's no way.
They'll never figure out- They'll never figure out via grab main.
That's the spirit.
Come at me again after all you've got.
I need to learn the chain grab.
Oh my god.
I'll be unstoppable!
Exactly.
I don't need to be good.
I just need to suck less than everyone else.
If only they had coaches to teach them then they could learn.
They'll never know!
They'll never expect me to be the- I'll practice king off stream and I'll play every other- I'll play all the other Tekken characters so they'll never know who my main is.
And I'll like hard grind king and all I do is just grab.
.
Surely they won't research my first stream.
Surely they wouldn't!
Yeah, okay.
We need to get the chain grab going and a lot of people can't counter it.
Before this gets tough.
I'll play every other character but king in the next couple of streams.
And then I'll hard grind and then they'll be like Oh my god.
Surely.
Doki Bird is like an eddy main.
So all we have to do is learn how to count- All you have to do newbies is to learn how to counter like the- Okay, but what if the other people play king?
Wait.
How am I gonna like- Oh my god!
I got the beast and like Oh my god I got player customization!
They'll never know.
They'll never know I'm a king main.
How would they know I'm a king main?
Oh wait, hey that's my avatar.
Wait, how do I- player customization?
Which one is- Use outfit- Oh here you go.
My title.
How would they know I'm a king main?
Will you and your players health gauge change the design of your player information?
Is that a magic mirror?
How would they know?
Let's see.
Where is- Where's the beast?
Wait, I got the title plate, right?
Where's the- Which one was it?
Is it this one?
Which one?
Which one was the one I unlocked?
Wait, that's so cute.
Was it legend plate?
Tekken emperor plate?
Which one was the one that I unlocked?
Guys.
Title?
Yeah, I know but which one is it called?
That's- Which one is it called guys?
I don't remember.
I unlocked it but I don't remember.
For down below the locked ones- Oh!
Wait no, these are paid.
I have to buy these.
Liars.
What is the one that I unlocked?
Oh, there it is.
How would they know?
Guys.
How would they know I'm a king main?
There's no way.
There's no fucking way they could find out.
Dude, he is all I need.
Wait, that's great.
Where's the one I unlocked for this?
Is it the play information panel?
You missed the beast.
Where is the beast?
Today's the day.
Where's the beast?
I can't find it.
I found tea drink.
Where the fuck is the beast?
Down?
It's further down?
Yeah, but these are all locked.
Where's the unlocked?
Oh, there it is.
That beast.
There we go.
They'll never know.
Guys, they'll never know I'm a king main.
How could they?
If they found out I'm the king main...
They're fucking stream snipers.
They'll keep it going.
They'll never know.
Save and exit.
There we go.
I'm sure they're 8 minute king guys.
There's no way.
I refuse to believe they'll find out.
If they find out they're hackers.
How would they know?
Exactly.
You know what?
I'm ready.
I'm fucking ready.
I'm so ready.
Not a king main.
This is it.
There.
Okay.
We'll do...
Max number of participants.
Wait.
Actually...
Fuck it.
We'll do...
There we go.
Alright.
There's no way.
They won't know.
Guys.
How would they know?
How could they possibly know?
The mind games?
That she really must not be a king main.
I'm not.
Who said I was?
I told you.
My server... My session...
says not a king main.
So how would they know?
Just saying.
No.
Just don't play...
Okay.
But how do I...
Wait.
How do I counter another king player?
It's so easy.
I'll grab them before they grab me.
Chat.
I'll grab the king player before they grab me.
And then it'll be GG's.
It'll be GG's from there.
It's hard to get a read on...
Quick guys!
Come in before... Guys!
Start.
Hurry up.
Join.
Click enter.
The online servers are going down in 2 minutes.
Hurry.
Join.
Click yes.
Wow.
You're so smart.
Grab them first before they grab me.
Exactly.
I'm going left side.
Where's king?
Oh nice.
There you go.
They'll never know.
I bet they don't know which one I picked.
Hurry!
Hurry up!
We need to dance.
We got to start.
It's okay.
I learned this.
Guys.
I've learned how to play.
They couldn't pause.
I bet they didn't expect it.
I bet...
Guys, I bet they didn't expect this.
There's no way.
Okay.
Oh yeah.
That's like a go- OH SHIT HE CATTERED MY GRUB AND NOW I'M LAYING!
OHHHHH HOW DID YOU KNOW?!
Oh my god!
How did she know?!
How- oh my god.
Guys, how the fuck did she know?!
I'm so sorry!
I don't- I don't understand!
How did she know?!
That's fucking right!
Yeah, counter this bitch!
You can't counter shit!
Oh god.
It's fine.
I got one in.
It's okay.
I got it.
OH MY GOD!
SHE'S COUNTERING MY G- EVERYTHING!
No way!
You can counter grabs?!
WHY?!
That's fucking right.
Counter this bitch!
It's okay.
I got my one.
I got my one grab.
That's all that matters.
That's fucking right.
That's fucking right!
Get K.O'd!
I learned!
I adapted!
Oh, you wanted grab too!
Yeah?
Oh my god!
She grabbed me!
How's that possible?!
Oh, she countered my grab!
How is that possible?!
Oh yeah?
I bet your whole idea is to counter all these grabs.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That's fucking right, but you didn't- SHE'S COUNTERING MY GRABS!
Get rekt.
Counter this.
Bitch.
That's icky.
That's icky, right?
You fucking didn't counter all of these, did ya?
That's icky, right?!
You didn't counter this!
I got one off you!
I have zero Tekken experience, but I took a round.
I took a round off her.
She knows how to Tekken.
What's embarrassing is that she- I took a round off her.
That's the embarrassing run.
That's right.
I got- She couldn't counter that!
I cleaned shit.
No one can deflect this.
Nooooo!
Alright, we'll do one- We'll do a story mode.
RIP online.
Just remember, the zero- The zero- The zero Tekken experience Doki Bird took a round off you by just spamming grab.
Let me in.
It's more embarrassing for you than it is for me to lose.
Cause it's expected.
But it was not expected for me to take a round off you.
I'm impressed.
Alright, nice.
Can I keep playing?
I'm a king.
I got the round one.
I have nothing- Exactly.
I have nothing to lose.
I have the moral victory.
My ego can only go higher.
Cause I start at rock bottom.
Not a king, man.
I don't play king in this mode?
What?
How can I exist?
Without king?
I play gym?
What the fuck?
I'm sorry for all the gyms out there.
What kind of fucking fighting character name is gym?
I'm fucking playing the office guy?
I'm gym mode.
I'm stuck with emo gym.
I'm playing the office.
Oh, Jin!
I thought you guys said gym.
I was like- Sorry.
Gym Tekken.
Sorry.
Jin.
It's Jin map.
I thought you guys- Sorry.
I can't read.
I thought it meant- I thought you guys said gym.
Okay, that's pretty badass.
I was like, why is his name Jim?
But his actual name is Jin.
No, his name is Jin now.
Mishima.
That his name?
I wish I was king.
I miss king, guys.
I already miss him.
Oh, that's a dad?
Oh shit!
Can he grab?
Alright, guys.
Oh!
Oh my gosh.
Okay.
I'm gonna use this other thing though.
Can you grab?
Wait, you can grab!
Wait, how good is your grab though?
Okay.
It's okay.
I'm just gonna keep grabbing.
Oh my god.
It's not the same.
It's not the same, guys.
His grab is not the same.
It's not the same as his grab.
It's king though.
King was cooler!
Wait, what?
Dodge.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Go look down.
Yeah, that's fucking right.
That's fucking right.
And then I'll do this again!
Yeah!
Oh shit!
Okay, I blocked it, I think.
Yeah, I did!
I did!
I blocked it!
Oh shit!
No no no no no no no!
Oh shit he shot me in the fucking gut.
Oh god.
Nice.
Alright.
Okay and then... PLEASE!
GRAB HIM JIN!
GRAB HIM!
YES!
GRAB HIM AGAIN!
WE'RE KING!
Guys I can't grab him.
By the way Doki, all you need to know about this family is that they like to keep throwing each other off really high cliffs.
Gladzo, thank you for the super chat!
Thank you!
The worst king.
This one goes out to king.
Oh shit!
Nice!
Good old fashioned family, Drow.
I love it when my frames go to 18.
Woah I have wings now?
Holy shit!
How many forms do I have?
Alright watch this.
I can block this.
Guys.
Guys I can block one.
Right?
There's no way.
Yes!
Okay I got it.
That was... I count that as a block.
I count...
I count that as a block guys.
Okay here we go.
Okay did I block that?
That... no I didn't.
No I didn't.
Holy shit!
Guys it's cause I gave him one!
Holy shit my laser eyes.
That's insane.
Oh nope.
How am I doing worse?
Oh I think that was a block.
I think I actually did that.
Oh god.
Okay.
No no no no no no.
Nice.
That's fine.
Okay.
No no no no no no.
Yes!
Blocked!
That's fucking right!
Oh no.
That's not okay.
No!
I tried to fly!
Why did I try to fly?
No!
Oh wait.
Nice.
The game protected me.
I blocked.
That's right guys.
Story mochis.
Guys what are you talking about?
I lived.
I lived guys.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Is this devil mode?
I guess because he has like black wings.
Am I gonna kill my dad?
This is not Clift.
Oh shit.
I love watching this in like 30 FPS.
Guys I perfected.
Because I had full HP when I...
I had full HP when I ended.
What the fuck?
Is he also a devil?
Woah.
What do I do?
Oh my god.
My lasers.
Okay.
I'm gonna block.
Oh shit!
How was I supposed to know he's a...
What?
What the fuck?
What is this?
Oh it's okay.
I grabbed.
And he counted my grab?
Guys this is bad.
The CPU is learning.
You're...
That's right.
I blocked low.
But I'll block high now.
No!
Oh my god.
Why is he so...
Guys it's because I'm not king.
I can't do this without king.
He was my crutch.
He was my fucking crutch.
What the fuck?
Oh my god.
He's so good.
I'm trying.
I need to stop grabbing because it's all I know.
It's actually all I know.
I'm so used to grabbing.
It's just pure instinct.
It's actually pure instinct.
My grabs.
I've been doing it so much.
Okay.
Nice.
I blocked this.
Oh!
He did though.
Oh god.
Oh.
It's okay.
Oh god it's not okay.
Oh god.
It's not okay.
It's like fucking all the time.
Oh.
Oh!
Why is he so good?
How is the AI learning so much from me?
It's actually insane.
The AI learned so much.
He regained Jace?
This is bullshit.
There you go.
I got grabbed him.
Oh my god.
I need to stop grabbing.
It's all I know.
It's actually all I know.
Doki they are unblockable in this game.
Anyway, good luck in learning the game.
Thank you for the first super chat.
Thank you.
Oh my god.
Please.
Holy shit.
I'm getting absolutely destroyed.
Oh.
Guys.
This is bad.
I'm actually getting absolutely destroyed there.
Okay.
I know how to kick though.
That's fucking right.
Oh no.
That's not good.
It's okay.
I still know how to grab.
This is my legacy.
My king instinct is taking over.
Hit him low then high.
Okay.
I got it.
Hit him low then high.
Oh my god.
But he hit back.
I can't believe it.
A fighting game and he hits back?
That's insane.
That's right.
I'll grab you.
That's fucking right.
Oh shit.
Nice.
Come on.
Yes.
Oh.
Hit him low.
Wait.
He's still alive?
I did it.
I learned.
What's going on?
What the fuck is going on?
I broke the crab?
How?
Hahaha.
I mean I knew how.
Of course.
Of course I know how.
Hahaha.
Random, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Whoa.
It's okay.
We can rebuild it.
Why we in New York?
Shouldn't we be in Japan?
Why not?
Oh and he chose New York?
That's fucked up.
Just another day in New York.
Oh my god, he's speaking in like...
Wow!
Hey, they're like universalists.
Do they all have like...
It's French!
Do they all have like earpieces that translate each language they're speaking?
They would never!
Yes, but they can't counter my grabs.
There's no way.
At best, if they get better, they won't be matching up with me.
Because as long as I don't improve...
As long as I don't improve, I'll still be matched up with all the people in my rank.
The fuck?
I'll be the one to replace you.
Yeah,
but like the thing is they have to...
We're matched up to like our level.
So I just like...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
No, I don't show my strats on stream.
That's the key.
I figured it out.
Like I said, I'll play everybody but King.
So they won't...
They won't think about countering me on King.
They'll like try to figure out how to counter me on every other character but King.
Oh, apparently all Tekken characters understand each other.
Wait, that's crazy.
That's... that's insane.
That's amazing.
I wish that was real.
I can just understand everybody else's languages.
Yeah!
Oh wait, there's me.
He wishes he was King.
What's that?
Is that me too?
Oh yeah, it's devil me.
Simple and clean.
Sora, wake up, Sora.
Wake up!
Oh, is that my mom?
I think he has mommy and daddy issues.
Developed by Bandai!
Whoa!
What's that?
He's better off as an orphan.
Not gonna lie with all those issues.
I feel like he'd be way more well adjusted if he was an orphan.
Yeah, he has mommy issues.
The issue is she's dead.
Oh my god!
What's this?
Mishima.
Wait, he's rich!
He's Mishima, right?
Oh my god, he's so rich.
How does he have so many issues?
It's because he's this rich that he has so many issues.
Oh my god, he's so rich.
He's so rich that he has so many issues.
He's so rich
that he has so many issues.
His dad is rich, him not so much, but then he gets the money passed down to him.
It's called inheritance.
He's rich, why evil?
If rich, why evil?
Okay, that counters each other.
If rich is evil.
No rich person is innocent.
That's how they get rich in the first place.
It's been one week since Kazuyo Mishima, head of G-Corporation, shot down the key military satellites.
While the militaries of the world are unable to function, the qualifiers for G-Corporation's tournament have begun.
The whole world is watching this tournament that gives power to the victorious country and levies penalties on the losers.
Charity is my power.
It's okay.
No matter where you are now.
I will not accept your doom.
You can do what you want.
I will not accept what you want.
Everyone has their own fate.
That's not what I want.
Also, I'm not a good confidant.
You're not good enough to make me cry.
You can't tell me you're not good.
I'm fine.
Thank you.
Here we go.
I got this.
Oh, I blocked!
Did you guys see that?
Oh my god!
Oh god.
Okay.
Wow!
Shit!
Did I block?
Oh shit!
Bro, sorry!
Actually got the tutorial.
Accident.
There you go.
Nice.
I stepped on him!
I blocked, guys.
I figured it out.
Oh shit!
Sorry, I got too excited.
I got so excited that I blocked that I forgot about everything else.
Okay.
Oh no.
No!
Wrong block!
Oh god.
Oh my god.
No!
He can't block!
He counters me!
No!
He learned my patterns!
Oh shit!
Oh no!
That's not good!
That's not good at all!
This is all I know how to do!
Oh shit!
No!
I lose?
I got one round off him!
How do I lose?
He gets two rounds and I get one?
This is absolutely bullshit.
I can't believe it.
This is so messed up.
It's fine.
No, no, no, no.
It's fine!
He's done CI!
I blocked so many!
Okay, and then he fucks me up.
There we go.
Oh, yeah, I see that.
Get comboed, dude!
Okay, they won't expect this.
The AI can't expect that.
I told you, the AI cannot expect that.
Guys, I got a combo going on!
Oh shit!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Grab him!
No!
Oh God!
Come on!
Nice!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Yes!
Grab!
Woop!
Yeah, I'm making progress!
How can you predict chaos exactly?
Yeah, they can't detect my combos if I don't know the combos.
Exactly!
Jin, show me the power of the devil.
Okay.
What's this?
Oh no, I'm having PTSD.
No, I'm not a Jin character!
I'm King!
And if you are one of the participants trying to scope up the competition, I am not a King player.
I was just joking.
I don't know how to play King.
I'm not King main, I swear.
I don't know who King is.
Who is King?
I've never seen that man in my life.
She's a robot?
Yeah, a robot would dress like that.
She seems like definitely a type of outfit where she can never take off.
AI generated faction!
I'm laughing.
I'm glad I don't have to lecture her.
J.
I'm a freak.
I can't believe she's a freak.
listening to music...
Jesus.
I'm a freak.
She's a freak.
Who are you going to kill me?
Come on.
Yeah!
He has to go!
He needs the money!
He needs the inheritance!
Wait, apparently the dad has 40 kids?
What happened to the 39 kids?
Oh, I think we all know what happened to the 39 kids.
Oh, grandpa has 40 kids!
Oh!
Wait, Lars is my brother?
39 kids left the church.
Oh, I'm going to chat.
Looking at two of them in this scene and saw one in the...
Wait!
Is this all just like... Oh, Lars is the uncle!
Oh, my grandpa is the asshole!
I see.
Or like, is my dad... my dad is the asshole?
And then he... him and the other is the... Lars and my dad is the... is...
Um... my... like, they're brothers?
Yeah, okay.
Oh, okay.
I'm starting to figure this out.
So, both grandpa and dad are bad people.
And I think my game crashed.
I can't tell yet.
I can't tell.
It's not moving!
Nothing's moving!
I can't tell!
Guys, I can't tell if it's baiting me.
Guys...
Did it crash?
I don't know!
Checking has baited me so often, I can't tell anymore!
Like, actually... I don't know.
Let it cook.
Okay.
The 8's not moving!
That's why!
I can't tell if terrible load times or if it's crashing!
I mean, to be fair, we did like...
We did like, survive for a while, though.
Is this crashed?
Okay, to be fair, I'll have to say, though...
We did get really far.
Okay, let's end this with a king fight.
I've learned so much with playing Jhin that I think we can end it on...
Let's do one last game and then we'll play king today.
I couldn't tell if it was loading or crashing.
I just decided to just force quit it.
Alright, here we go.
Yeah, I couldn't tell if it was loading or not.
It's so hard to tell for this game.
Tekken is like...
I just couldn't tell.
Is the maintenance over?
Is it?
Fancy, welcome to the tomato farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Hey, the 8 is moving, though.
Yay, Bandai!
Alright, here we go.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Grandpa threw dad off the cliff, so dad threw grandpa in the volcano.
This is the whole story from Tekken 1 to 7.
That's all we need to know.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
King's death roll?
What's that?
Um, Alexis, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You gotta learn the Korean backdash and King's death roll.
Oh, shit!
I got all that.
But I don't need that.
Alright, let's see.
Uh...
Versus CPU.
Okay.
Alright.
Yeah, I'm ready to rep Tekken 8 at EVO.
Okay.
This is it.
Wait.
Okay.
This is it.
Guys, I learned so much from King.
That I think I got this.
It's gonna be so easy.
I can feel it.
All I have to do is grab.
Alright.
Hard?
You know what?
I think I'm ready for hard level.
I'm ready for hard level.
I'll do random.
Take me anywhere in the world.
Urban Square?
Let's go.
This is it.
I'll show you guys.
I'll show you my power level right here.
By the way, if you're scoping out the competition, if any of like coaches or like team, like participants scoping out the competition, I'm not a King Ming.
I'm just...
I... I... I...
This is my very first time playing him.
But I'll never main this character ever in my world.
I'll never main him at all.
I'm just messing about.
Guys, did I crash?
Or is this loading?
We'll never know.
Guys, the 8's not moving guys.
Guys.
The 8's not moving.
I can't tell.
It crashed.
No!
It's forever.
Let's play a little game guys.
Did the game crash?
Guys, it's just because I love the main menu so much.
I swear I'll set up my new PC after before the tournament.
I swear.
I swear guys.
I'll definitely set up my new PC before the tournament.
Guys, it'll be fine.
We'll be fine.
We'll be so healthy.
Guys.
For any of my future competitors, I'm going to be an Eddy main.
So just learn how to counter the Eddy spam.
That's all you need to know.
I will never play any other hero but Eddy.
I swear.
100% truth.
This will be the only time I ever play King today.
True.
So true.
Guys, I don't even think I can get into the main menu anymore.
I'm going to be like, Is this a crash or is this loading for a very long time?
Is this...
I like this little game we play, chat.
This little fun game that we play.
Yeah, Eddy, my favorite Apex Legends.
I don't think this is loading anymore.
It's part of the experience.
It's part of the experience, chat.
Guys.
Oh, it has to be loading.
My cursor is gone.
The 8 appeared.
Oh no, my...
It's loading.
Look, the 8.
I swear the 8 was moving earlier.
See, it's moving.
Bandai.
Okay, there we go.
This is it.
This time.
This time I can fight.
Guys.
Where's the main menu?
Oh, there he is.
There's Eddy.
Eddy, there you are.
I knew you were going to be here.
All right.
Main menu time.
We made it.
We made it to the menu.
We did it.
We actually made it to the menu, everybody.
No, my PC is okay.
Shh, PC, it's okay.
They don't mean that.
I'll never replace you.
Shh.
I swear PC, the Hyatt, the Hyatt PC is just naver decoration.
I swear, I would never do anything to you.
Right, Let's see.
Practice vs CPU.
I don't mean it.
It's not lagging.
It's just your stream.
Dream!
4k anime...
It's all low quality, it can't be 4k.
Alright, there you go.
Alright, my very first time playing King.
My very first time.
Never touched this character in my life.
Unlucky, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Anton, thank you for the super chat.
Alright, hard.
This is it.
We got this.
Is that like...
Pshh, PC, he does...
They don't mean this.
I can't wait to just listen to this song.
This is like the soundtrack simulator.
Oh my god!
Nice.
Now we're at midnight.
Okay, how far did we get last time?
Here!
This is how far we got to, right?
I'm ready.
I'm ready for the next battle.
Guys, the particles stopped...
The particles are moving!
Guys, the particles stopped.
The particles stopped moving.
I don't feel the...
Guys, the particles stopped moving.
Why is the particles not moving?
Please.
Oh, it's moving!
We're so back!
There's me!
My 25th phrase!
It's okay, shh.
It's okay, PC.
I'll never leave you.
We don't need phrase for the grab.
It's okay, PC.
Please stay strong for me.
I don't know what's happening.
Stay strong, PC.
Stay...
Okay, here we go.
This is it.
Boom!
And then they'll never expect this.
Hard!
That's fucking right!
First time playing King, by the way.
I'll never play him again.
I swear.
Fight!
By the way, I swear I will not play him again for all the people scoping out the competition.
There you go.
Oh!
Oh, don't worry.
I got this.
I got this!
Boom!
And then I got this!
Yeah!
And I can grab you!
Easy!
Not a King Ming, by the way.
We're so back.
Oh, shit.
How are you gonna counter this?
Bam!
How the fuck did you counter this?
You don't.
You don't counter this.
Boom!
And then I swing you!
Look at me go!
And then stab!
We did it.
Easy.
This is hard CP!
Oh, shit!
Go, King!
Go!
How did she do it?
Don't worry, I'll never touch King again!
Sure, that was hard?
That was hard!
Yeah!
It was!
I know the combo!
Go, Ultra Heart!
Wait, how do I do Ultra Heart?
Do I just do rematch?
If I click rematch, can I change the difficulty from rematch?
That's not my main!
I don't know why you guys keep saying King is my main.
What the f***?
Do I just do like quick select?
Oh, quick select.
Okay.
Alright.
This is confirmed.
And then...
Alright, and then... wait, how do I...
Wait, no, I don't wanna be... no, I'm King!
I'm King!
Okay, there we go.
Very hard.
Alright, here we go.
I'm ready.
I'm so ready.
This is it.
Okay.
Let's see.
Oh, s***!
That is ultra hard!
Oh my...
Oh my god, that is ultra hard!
Who would've thought?
That is ultra hard, guys!
Oh my god, he's countering stuff now.
That's right, but you can't counter this!
He countered it.
But it's okay, he doesn't know about this.
Get grabbed!
Oh, you thought that was a grab?
No, no, no!
Oh, s***!
That's f***ing right.
I didn't grab this tab.
Oh, s***!
That's right, but I blocked.
Oh my god, that's a lot of energy!
Oh, he went double mode!
He went sicko mode!
But I also went sicko mode.
That's f***ing right.
Nice.
Oh, s***.
Oh my god, he's countering me.
How does he know?
How does he know what I wanna do?
I don't understand.
That's fine.
But I can do this, though.
And I can do...
Woah, s***!
Oh, s***!
No!
Oh god, oh god!
Come on, come on, counter!
No, no, no!
No, no!
Oh god.
Nice.
Okay.
No!
How does he read my input?
How does he know?
I don't understand.
How does he...
How does he know what I wanna do?
That's crazy.
But it's too bad.
It's over.
It's so over!
I told you.
I knew it!
No AI can download this!
No AI can download this brain!
No AI...
No AI can read what's going on in this brain!
Go ultra-hard?
Alright, let's do it.
Now go ultra-hard.
Alright.
That's f***ing right, I don't care.
We go harder.
Ultra-hard!
Get ready for the next battle!
King main by the way.
Just so you guys know, I'm just naturally gifted.
Hey, I can't read this.
Oh shit, that's fucking right.
You didn't expect me to go that way, right?
That's fucking right.
Oh, oh shit.
Oh shit, but can you escape the grab?
No, you can't.
That's fucking right.
You can't escape the grab!
The grab!
Now swing him!
Escape this, nerd!
That's right, you don't expect this!
He expected it, guys.
But did he expect this, though?
I'm too powerful.
Oh no, wait, JK.
Yeah?
No, uh-uh.
CPU!
No, no, no, CPU!
Oh no.
Easy.
How does she keep getting away with this?
The Doki Grab!
Oh my god, the Doki Grab is back!
It's back!
It never left!
The Doki Grab never leaves!
Oh god, it's actually input reading me now.
Holy shit, he actually knows now.
Oh, fuck!
How does he know?
Okay.
Oh my god, how the fuck...
How the fuck does he know this has been my strength this entire time?
Ultra hard goes hard!
Oh, nice.
It's fine.
No!
It's not fine!
It's learning!
Please, the counter!
Grab it!
It's learning me!
Holy shit, he figured it out!
How did he figure- I don't understand.
How does he figure this out?
No, no, no.
I can do it too.
I can also do it... this.
Oh my god.
Nice.
That's fine.
It's okay.
We'll be fine.
It's not okay.
Oh my god.
He... no.
Please just... I need one grab.
I need one grab!
Yes!
Oh my god!
Yeah!
Undefeated!
Let's go!
It's not hard enough.
Let's fucking go!
I figured it out!
Doki the King.
Oh my god!
I can't believe I did this without my main character!
Not a King main!
Alright.
I think...
I think that's a good time to call it for today.
Doki the King.
The Ultra Hard Master.
They need a harder mode for me!
Oh my god!
GG's everybody.
Oh what a way to call it here.
I can't believe it.
We got all the way to Ultra Mode.
We fucking did it!
We fucking did it guys!
Oh!
Anyway.
I'm gonna call it here everyone.
We had two streams today.
So today is a good time to rest now.
I have a lot of work to do today.
So it was a great time to stream Tekken for the first time.
Tekken 8 for the first time.
And playing it for the first time.
A lot of fun.
A lot of fun guys.
Especially taking some sets off of it.
I got the fucking, quote unquote.
Not pros, sorry!
Quote unquote the good players of my dragoons.
You should be ashamed if I took a set off you!
You should be ashamed!
Alright guys, so for those who are new here.
The reason why I'm playing Tekken 8.
Is because I got invited to do Sajan Slam 2.
Two!
So obviously I'm a noob so I'll be put in the noob category with everybody else.
So like noobs will be fighting other noobs and that's why I'm learning a character that a noob might have difficulty with.
So...
Which is not King, it's Eddie.
Guys.
I'm talking about Eddie, not King.
Um...
Anyway.
Who's my trainer and coach?
I don't know!
I don't know.
I'm just waiting for...
Apparently this was the stream for them to figure out how they're gonna balance it.
So like I hope that I look really bad.
So I...
I'm a new player!
I'm a new player.
I have no idea what I'm actually doing.
So like we had to do a stream where like...
We had to do at least an hour stream so they can gauge our skill level.
So by the way, I'm a new player.
Please treat me as a new player.
Hahaha.
I'm so bad.
I can only go up.
I'm at rock bottom.
Anyway guys.
As always everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Cause you deserve it!
I'll see you guys next time everybody!
Bye guys!
Bye!